I hear people shine you know how to make
a million dollars right where are you
you ain't dead I wouldn't be how to make
a million dollars like what does that
mean so now how do you do it how do you
make some money from it I'm gonna give
you three ideas on how to execute you
got a master what you're going to master
too many people are jumping from place
to place to place rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
live what you're talking about over you
Eric Thomas also if you want to hear it
Eric Thomas and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series I have a ritual where
even if you're my closest friend I have
boundaries you've got to make a
sacrifice if you don't get to the next
level you're gonna have to give up
something right you're gonna have to
give up something and I'm just gonna
keep it real with y'all when I've been
telling you to get that gold get that
dream and I'm just been telling you
drive it and drive it and drive it and
drive it what I've been talking about is
consistency every day for the next 254
days I will send you a 30-second to 5
minute video for free every morning to
help you build unstoppable confidence
the link is in the description below
you want to get your credit up and
whatever you're doing you know I'm
saying I think shine if you and I both
sat here and talked about health you'd
blow me out to water you know I'm saying
and not just the information but you've
been doing it in terms of the physical
working out for years you also had an
ailment that you know that you studied
and was like I gotta get through this
you know you you you actually helped
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people do it so there's a credibility
that you have because you've become one
with the with what you're doing whereas
somebody who read a book and then say it
it's like ah that's good information but
some kind of way it's not coming across
the right way so I think the first thing
you need to do is like literally live
what you're talking about and I think a
lot of people you know like I hear
people shine you know how to make a
million dollars I'm like were you you
ain't dead wouldn't be how to make a
million dollars like what does that mean
like you're making that up you don't
really believe that you know or you
haven't lived it to influence people you
have to speak your truth if you want to
win if you want to stand out if you want
to be the big competition you want to
gain attention you have to speak what's
true to you from your experience in the
stuff that you've actually gone through
or I think a lot of people are talking
about things that are not as relevant to
them it's think that you might aspire to
be in which case the journey is what you
want to showcase but don't try to be an
expert on something that you're not an
expert on because people will see
through it you won't have success people
have incredibly high BS meters and if
you're talking things that are not true
to you you will not win so as an example
I had somebody come through my workshop
in May but making money as a thought
leader and she had some abuse in her
life and she was afraid to share the
abuse and she didn't want to talk about
it and and it was something that she
cared a lot about but she didn't know
how to get it out there understand that
as much as I might care about abuse
someone like me like I think it's
terrible I think I feel so bad with
people who have suffered through it
abuse isn't part of my story I've never
been abused by my parents by people in
my live family school I've never been
abused so as much as I can talk about it
you know just I don't like it I feel bad
for the people who've gone through it I
can't
really share anything solid because I
have it's not my story I haven't gone
through it's not my truth
and so if you want to help people it's
only through your truth through what you
have gone through through your
experiences
I love entrepreneurs I love talking
about how much foreigners are gonna save
the world but also recognize a struggle
in certain business because I lived it
because I hated myself in the early days
of being an entrepreneur because I had
really negative feelings I I struggled I
was making $300 a month I couldn't
afford to have a full meal at McDonald's
like I've lived that life I've been
there it was insanely painful and now I
want to make it easier for other people
so that's the truth that I can connect
with and talk to every day but a lot of
other stuff I can't so I'm I'm very
narrow in my lane and same thing for you
you will find your path you will win by
actually doing the thing that you're
talking about by speaking your truth so
now how do you do it how do you make
some money from it I'm gonna give you
three ideas on how to execute one is
understand that your purpose comes from
your pain people try to run away from
their pain they try to forget their pain
they try to for try to block out all a
negative stuff that happens them in the
past that's actually the source that's
actually the fuel go into it run dive
deep headfirst right into it instead of
trying to run the other way and block it
out it was my biggest challenge I think
I try to forget negative experiences I'm
so heavy on the optimism and positivity
side that I blocked it out and had to
resurface these old memories but my pain
of dealing with the struggling business
and eventually getting through it is why
I do what I do is why I make these
videos is why I get up every day and try
to help entrepreneurs because I want to
make the path a little bit less painful
for other people coming through it so
the pain that you went through if you
think back like what would the most
painful moments in your life the moments
where you just felt helpless the moments
where you feel insanely frustrated the
moments we felt like life was over a
life was terrible or it's not worth
living or whatever the darkest parts
inside you from the past that's the path
because as you've gone through those
things if you're still on your journey
if you're a little bit ahead of somebody
else you can serve the answer isn't just
to sit in the pain and Walla wet and
feel bad again it's to recognize that
because I went through this and because
I can tap into those feelings again I
can serve
that's how you bring the positivity back
that's where the light is I can serve
others who have gone through or who are
right now going through that thing I
want to be a servant to them I want to
help them and that you'll be able to
speak your truth because you understand
what they actually felt like having
dealt with that situation yourself so
your purpose comes from your pain dive
into it number two is you got to
practice you got to practice getting
your message out there you got to
practice being a thought leader you got
to practice influencing people this
start you're not going to be great at it
if you've never told your story if
you've been too embarrassed to tell this
thing that happened to you like you got
abused and you're ashamed of it and you
don't want to share that with the world
then imagine all the other people who
are also ashamed of it by you coming out
and seeing what happened now you give a
shield to other people to feel like it's
okay for them to tell their story as
well you need to be courageous first and
other people being inspired by that and
be courageous in return and so you need
to practice telling your story you need
to practice getting your ideas out there
and my favorite suggestion for you is
going Instagram stories and do three to
five every single day Instagram stories
delete up to 24 hours they're meant to
be informal and rough cause not fancy
video like this and nobody's watching at
the beginning so it's okay you're gonna
suck and that's awesome and nobody's
watching you anyway so feel free to suck
right three to five stories every single
day practice practice practice practice
practice every time you do it every day
you get better you will improve and
every time you improve you'll be the
shift a few more people are fewer people
a few more people and then they're
saying that this thing that you went
through it was so painful as you get
better in your ability to communicate
and tell your story you'll be able to
serve more people and help more people
along the path and set number three is
start making money now whatever the
thing is whatever the solution was for
you it might have been a long hard path
to get through it but you can help other
people through a product through service
and you can make money doing it
so for example if meeting people of
having some kind of mastermind was
helpful for you or counseling or
coaching was helpful for you you could
be that person for other people you
could be the mastermind you could be the
coach it could be the consultant if you
have tons of knowledge in your head you
can write it down into a book and start
selling that but the best books the best
coaching programs the best products
again still come down to your truth like
this helped
you this book helped me all the content
in this book helped me this book helps
me still does all the contents in this
book still help me all the videos that I
make on my channel I still learn
something from or I don't post them they
still help me and so because it's based
off of my truth people want to consume
them and that's how you can make money
think about your shortcut in the path to
solving that problem whatever that
problem was you faced it was so painful
for you it may have taken you five years
ten years to overcome it maybe you're
still in the process of overcoming it
but to get from where you were in that
deep dark hole to where you are right
now even though it's not perfect yet you
could take that five ten year period and
squish it down into 30 days for somebody
and you can sell that recipe you can
sell that technique as long as whatever
it is that you're selling you
fundamentally believing like you wish
that you had this when you were in the
hole I wish that I had my youtube
channel and these two books when I was
in the hole didn't believe in myself
when I was 19 and struggling as an
entrepreneur shortcut in the path
provides insane value based off of your
truth and gives you a path to make money
in the process as well now I've got a
special bonus clip that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know your purpose comes from
your pain what is your purpose what is
the pain and what is the purpose now
what did you suffer through and how do
you want to make that road easier for
the next generation people that you can
serve them leave that in the comments
below I'm curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot a vinspresso
and enjoyed the bonus
[Music]
being great at your craft is a
requirement yeah yeah and I'm not I
wouldn't suggest that you stop that you
don't try and get work or hustle or do
all those other things while you're
coming up because that's a part of the
game and that's you know Gary Vee is a
big advocate for hustling and so you got
to hustle your whole way but being great
at your craft actually matters yeah yeah
and and having like the camera is like
an extension of my arm and you think
about it I have used the pro golf
analogy I don't know why I not crazy
about golf but those guys have to again
women have to stand up on the tee and
hit the ball in the middle because
that's what they're paid to do doesn't
matter if it's raining sunny windy if
there's ten people watching or ten
million they're paid at the ball in the
middle and as an artist you're paid to
make and as an entrepreneur you're paid
to deliver the the ROI to the
shareholders and as a wrestler you're
paid to win or like whatever your thing
is you have to be great at your craft in
order to I think achieve so there's this
10,000 hours hardcore the folks that I
think are great whether they're hacking
the system and doing it in 10 hours or
10,000 that is I think people want to
skip that step
yeah I get I get you know for every
email that I get about the craft of
writing yeah I get a thousand about how
to market books and I'm just like the
ratio is all wrong yep so no I would
agree with that and so that gets
overlooked like I just want to be this
awesome
fashion photographer and hang out with
like awesome you know beautiful people
in crazy locations and it's like dude
you got a beat I can actually pick up a
camera and get good that first and then
you might be able to do you know when I
started starting everyone says aw you're
gonna be a gym teacher I said no I saw
my work with professional athletes I
knew what I wanted to do is I'm gonna
work with but I'm going to work with
professional athletes so that was my
that was the goal I set in my mind and I
just said hey that that's gonna take a
place in my head that's the only thing
that I want to do and I gotta figure out
a way to I got to figure out a way to
get there so I started and learned my
craft better than anybody else did I
start with the professional athletes
knowing after I graduated I went to work
in a local health club really I knew how
I knew everything from a book standpoint
but still you gotta know how
apply it okay so I you know worked with
anybody I could any these are not pro
these aren't pros I'm talking about
housewives I'm talking about individuals
that just want to get in just want to
get in shape people that have had
injuries from different sports kids
anybody just kind of developing programs
putting implementing what I've learned
and actually being able to apply it
mm-hmm and once I start look at that
craft I said okay now I'm starting to
figure out how to actually apply this
stuff and how to use it and put the
formulas together and put the workouts
together and do all these different
things I mean stuff that they're doing
now from a workout standpoint I was
doing 30 years ago I know I mean some of
the stuff is you are it's different I
stay on top of it right I got to
continue to learn you know continue to
be better myself so I can better my
athletes better my craft but it it's a
different it's just a different way of
doing the same a different way of doing
the same thing right now there's a lot
more resources a lot more education a
lot more testing available back then you
kind of had to just figure it out a lot
of individuals now okay especially in
this generation not only from a training
standpoint but from a knowledge
standpoint they're jumping from one
thing to another
you know they're using this trainer this
week they're using another trainer next
week you know they're using this person
as a mentor on YouTube than they're
using this person over here okay and
they're getting all this conflicting
information okay you got a you got a
master what you're going to master okay
you have to fit you have to figure out
too many people are jumping from place
to place the place Michael
Kobe all these individuals they mastered
one aspect of the game when they
mastered that aspect of the game then
they move to another aspect of the game
get great at your craft
look you have a gargantuan competitive
advantage because most people are caught
up or card-carrying members and I say
this with respect but it's reporting
reality most people in the world right
now in business are card-carrying
members of the cult of
IATI in a previous episode and I share
this in my leadership presentations I
believe the world today is suffering and
that word I'm choosing it consciously
and carefully from the collective deep
professionalization of business a little
while ago I was in an airport there was
a elevator repairman and he had his
boombox cranking out hard rock well
that's fine but he's at work he's not at
home I go into a store these days there
are people listening to music out loud
when they should be taking care of
customers you walk into an airport and
you see people behind the desk or
whatever
rather than being pros owning the game
you literally see them chit-chatting or
again looking at videos of dancing cats
and people riding bicycles off the roofs
of their houses you know what I'm
talking about I call it the collective
deep professionalization of business
very few people relatively speaking
right now say this is my craft I've got
to be a pro I've got to study the audio
books that relate to my game I've got a
fine Mentors I've got to read the books
I've got to practice like Federer or
Serena Williams or Muhammad Ali used to
practice you know Mahmoud Ali once said
he said I hated every single one of
those early morning runs but I loved the
idea of being champion of the world
now terrific world domination honey
Empire right I'm grateful I understand
why I'm here I think because I am so
open I wanted to think and see it's a
bloody brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous success if you want to know
what garyvee DJ khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video